we are awaiting a news conference this
afternoon after the Biden Administration
makes a stunning urn on its border
policy as we get new video of hundreds
of migrants rushing the Border overnight
Homeland Security secretary Alejandro
mayorcas is set to wave over two dozen
federal laws to expedite the Urgent
construction of a border wall in Texas
to stem the historic flow of migrants
hello everyone this is outnumbered I'm
Emily compano here with my co-hosts
Harris Falkner and Kaylee mckinin and
also joining us today Fox News
contributor and board certified
physician Dr Nicole Sapphire and the
32nd under Secretary of the army former
Pennsylvania congressman and Iraq combat
veteran Patrick J Murphy now dramatic
new video from El Paso showing hundreds
of migrants charging the Border in a
full run chanting C pu or yes it can be
done
[Applause]
that is just one incident of migrants
flooding the Border
260,000 have been encountered last month
alone the highest monthly total ever
recorded perhaps this is why the
administration is finally changing its
tune on the border crisis which remember
they refused to even site as such with
an secretary mcus saying quote there is
presently an acute and immediate need to
construct physical barriers and roads in
the vicinity of the border of the United
States in order to prevent unlawful
entries into the United States now
that's interesting considering former
president Trump was hammered for
demanding a wall watch but we need the
wall and it has to be built and we want
to build it
fast the number of illegal immigrants
crossing our borders is so so large that
we've nowhere to hold them and President
Biden vowed he'd never build one there
will not be another foot of Wall
constructed on my
Administration Congressman a massive
U-turn a massive U-turn but a much
needed one emway the fact is this is
that the primary and sacred duty of our
government is to keep our family safe
here at home this is a national security
issue a humanitarian crisis not just on
the border but also in our cities like
New York Chicago and elsewhere so it is
about time and I think we're all
thrilled As Americans that they're
getting a message all right well let's
talk about that a little bit Kaye
because we have for example some sound
of just exactly what those Chicago
residents how they feel about the Border
crisis that has affected all 50 states
watch you cannot keep bringing
immigrants in the city does not have the
money you cannot track them you ain't
tracking them good at the police station
you don't know their name but you want
to spare them all over the city it is
unsanitary it's unsafe and it's just not
right now those are just some of the
voices but it's reflected in larger
National polls this absolute dereliction
of Duty and the fact that everyone is
disapproving of the way Biden has been
handling immigration to the tune of 62%
Kaye yeah that's right I'm not surprised
uh the hypocrisy here is just oozing
from this Administration from the day
One Promise of Biden building a massive
wall that spans the entire Southern
border is not a serious solution my
favorite though is Karine John Pierre
you can always go to her for the best
sound bites from this Administration go
over to her she was asked about a border
wall you know what she said the reason
we can't have a border wall heavy wins
her direct quote it would waste taxpayer
dollars on an ineffective wall that
can't withstand heavy wins so all of a
sudden I love today's briefing I think
it's 1: p.m. someone ask her did the
winds change why can we have a border
wall now but over the summer the heavy
winds were impediment also someone needs
to ask the media when Trump tried this
built nearly 500 mil of border wall
Bloomberg this isn't a border wall it's
a monument to white supremacy New York
Times Trump's Wall of Shame they call it
a reminder of white racial hostility and
NBC Trump's border wall was never about
security it's meant to remind Latinos
there unwelcome so media where are the
headlines like that they don't exist uh
the hypocrisy from the White House can't
wait to hear kjp at one Harris you've
covered extensively how the families
feel how the citizens feel border patrol
getting killed in record numbers
committing suicide in record numbers
people having to take out loans for
their school supplies like the
individual stories and the horrors that
these states and these law enforcement
officers have been experiencing for so
long while this Administration refused
to cite it as a crisis or even turn any
eye toward it now we get this at the
11th hour I guess I'm grateful but I
can't help being so angry that for so
many years everyone was ignored yeah you
know what um that's why this isn't going
to be enough because this is politics
he's flexing he just you know had the9
billion relief in school debt loans he
sees those polling numbers and this is
another flex and it is so corrosive
politically for him right now to turn a
blind eye that they're willing to do
something that he said he'd never do he
ran on being the opposite of trump he
flipped the switch on so many policies
particularly within the L of Biden's
border crisis I mean it it it started to
get worse almost the day he got into
office so to Simply Now do this without
acknowledging I think you need a
fireside chat I think you need to tell
the people in this country that we are
your first priority and to thank those
border agents and their families because
the entire family serves when that man
or woman goes out for 30 and 48 hour
shifts at a time you don't think they're
missed
oh they're missed he owes them the
Gratitude and the apology for it having
taken so long and you know what else he
owes he owes money to States like Texas
and those people who have broken their
bank accounts and their backs to try to
make it work for the more than 7 million
that have come across the border on his
watch he owes a lot right now and I
don't know if you can ever get that back
without acknowledging it first and I
will say this you have never changed
your tune you have been right there you
and representative quar you've been
right there and you're not from a border
state well I appreciate it Harris and I
would say not just the the Bol agents
who are heroes and their families but
also the fact that you have Democratic
leaders that are stepping up JB pritzer
who's the governor of Illinois mayor
Adams here New York had to get back in
Chicago for him right but and even in
New York I mean there's 100,000 migrants
here in the city of New York so again we
need to come Together As Americans to
solve this national security issue and
by the way China is exploiting this
China is sending fentanyl the precursor
drugs for fentanyl which has killed
100,000 Americans last year well you
know we know so doctor let's talk about
priorities for a second because part of
the consistently reflected sentiment of
American people is how forgotten they
are not just and most importantly law
enforcement but everyday citizens
because they see stuff like this here is
a list of the things that are given to
undocumented immigrants from some state
and local governments housing cash
assistance Education Health Care food
foreclosure prevention legal report I
have seen lines of people of Americans
who are waiting for those things to be
given to them that they have earned and
yet that's handed out along with iPhones
well we've heard some of the sound bites
coming out of Chicago where you have
American citizens who are saying that
they are feed they're already feeling at
the bottom of the barrel yet all of
these resources are being prioritized to
the illegal migrants coming through I
mean the reality is the United States
has become a willing facilitator in the
largest human and drug trafficking that
we've probably ever seen and yet we
still the response is completely
disjointed you have blinkin mayorcas and
Garland down in Mexico right now to talk
about fenel coming from China and also
the migrant situation but then you also
have mayor Adams going down to Mexico
himself separately it's like clowns
getting out of a clown car they're not
actually working together here and to
bring it down to a basic level they
rolled back the Trump era policies we
know that happened and since then over 6
million migrants have crossed the border
that's six times the population of Rhode
Island so call it a barrier not a wall
call it the stay put in Mexico not
remain in Mexico but whatever you have
to do we have to do something and it's
unfortunate that it has taken these
Democrats now calling to the White House
saying hey our seats are up for grabs in
legislation for something to be done
that 6 million doesn't count the one and
a half million Goda aways that came into
the country that's how I get to 7.0
exactly and those kids are still missing
it is still a crisis it is still Biden's
America unfortunately hey everyone I'm
Emily compano catch me and my co-hosts
Harris vulner and Kaylee mcki on
outnumbered every weekday at 12:00 p.m.
Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights